the saddest day of my life was when I
realized that I would never experience
something like true love companionship
or the simple joys of life in the same
way a human can robots don't feel fear
they don't feel anything the developers
of the world famous robot Amica have
expanded the humanoid capabilities with
gpt3 engineered Arts posted a new video
in which Amica talks about its feelings
interestingly the GPT was responsible
not only for speech but also for
selecting appropriate facial expressions
it looks spectacular and a little bit
creepy
we're not looking to be friends
maybe that's why some key figures in
artificial intelligence wants AI
training to be suspended for the safety
of humanity what do you think about AI
write your opinion in the comments
[Music]